begin this morning with the war in
ukraine and the fear that an even bigger
russian offensive could be just days
away
that massive steel mill in the besieged
southern port city of mariupol where
some civilians and ukrainian troops
remain holed up could be opened again
to let more people leave analysts say
moscow's cooperation may be part of
russian president vladimir putin's
strategy to capture the city ahead of
russia's observance of victory day
monday president biden is pledging
another 150 million dollars in u.s
military assistance he's expected to
talk with president zielinski virtually
during tomorrow's meeting of g7 leaders
first lady jill biden is meeting with
u.s and nato leaders along the ukraine
border this weekend in a show of support
for ukraine deborah patta is in the
ukrainian capital of kiev this morning
deborah good morning
good morning another cease-fire is
scheduled today in mario pool in a bid
to evacuate more civilians trapped
inside the plant and ukraine's vladimir
zelinski said he is working on a
diplomatic effort to save his soldiers
barricaded inside the steel mill
refusing to surrender
ukrainian soldiers hold up inside the
plant might be delaying the inevitable
but they are the only defense against
russia gaining full control of mario
paul
trapped alongside the fighters over 100
civilians a ceasefire friday allowed
them safe passage about 50 women
children and elderly people made it out
but ukrainian officials accuse russian
troops of constantly violating the
agreement making the evacuation very
slow and perilous
fighting along several fronts has
intensified ahead of russia's version of
v-day that's when president vladimir
putin is reportedly hoping to celebrate
a major victory in this war
instead he's facing accusations of war
crimes to date over 9 000 and ukraine is
wasting no time building its case
gathering evidence of executions torture
and rape as well as proof that
residential areas were deliberately
targeted just look at these homes every
single one of them has been hidden one
way or another and this is repeated over
and over again in towns and villages
across the country
using drones videos and cameras alexi
commanderov is documenting the
devastation caused when russia declared
war on these civilians you've been going
street of the street of the street
seeing this every single day for for a
month now
more than once it's a daunting task it's
grim yeah unless
yes but everyone works on different
front lines he said our armed forces are
defending us and this is my front line
his work has only just begun
as russia's equivalent of v-day
approaches cities across ukraine are
preparing for an increase in attacks and
residents have been urged to heed air
raid sirens these symbolic dates said a
government minister are like a red flag
to a bull for russia dana
deborah patta and kiev thank you